some places are Banning chemical
sunscreens because of the idea that they
harm coral reefs instead these places
are promoting mineral sunscreens there
are actually a lot of studies showing
that zinc oxide is toxic to Coral and
other aquatic organisms for example
these data tables come from a 2022
National academies report each of these
rows is an example of a harmful effect
that zinc oxide is being found to have
there's also this diagram that compares
the toxicity of different chemical and
physical sunscreen ingredients the lower
a DOT is on this graph the more potently
harmful it is you can see that both zinc
oxide and titanium dioxide the other
natural sunscreen can start causing harm
at lower concentrations than some
unnatural chemical sunscreens if you
look up the safety data sheet for zinc
oxide you'll see this symbol featuring a
dead fish it's surrounded by warnings
about how it's very toxic to Aquatic
Life neither chemical nor physical
sunscreen seem to be a big issue for
coral reefs but it's pretty clear that
zinc oxide isn't a completely safe
alternative